deaf no that's right I make movie
reviews now two weeks after anyone cares
about the movie anymore
yes deaf no have you seen it I got a lot
of people asking me about the movie and
you know I have a lot of thoughts about
it so I thought why not share them with
the world listen to me what I have to
say you probably have seen or heard of
Death Note it's in Japanese manga that
was made into an anime and then that was
made into it I think it was already made
to a live-action but here it is again
thanks to Netflix a live movie
adaptation of an anime oh boy
I'm sure it will be the greatest film of
all time I'm sure Netflix won't [ __ ] it
up at all just like they did not at all
ruin my favorite manga of all time blam
you did not completely butcher that [ __ ]
no not at all now I feel ashamed liking
plan because of how goddamn awful the
anime is thanks Thank You Netflix
basically Netflix bought the rights to
to death no because it's not on
crunchyroll you can only watch it on
Netflix legally and it's probably their
most popular anime I imagine it's the
most popular one because whenever
someone asked me who doesn't watch anime
what anime to watch I always recommend
them def note because it's such a
classic and it's so easy to get into so
I always recommend that so it makes
sense that it's the most popular one on
Netflix and for them to then make a live
movie adaptation of it if they own the
rights for it and it's just gonna bring
in more attention to it and you know
from a business standpoint I understand
it I just don't understand what the hell
that we're doing with this goddamn movie
Death Note has suffered enough if you
ask me okay they're all the angsty
teenagers that almost ruined death notes
almost they almost ruined Death Note but
you know i rewatch it not long ago and
it it still adds up it's still an
amazing anime I still would recommend
people to watch it for sure but if you
haven't seen definitely let me just
explain the plot it's very simple it's
the story of Yagami like my favorite
anime
doctor of all Tam who discovers this
Death Note by chance and in it if he
writes a person's name while thinking of
that person's face that person will die
so Yagami light is this genius who life
is just too simple for him he's too
smart for people and he's just bored so
for him to discover something like this
he immediately thinks okay well I'm
gonna use this for the greater good of
humanity
I'm gonna start killing all the
criminals so you have this extremely
intelligent person in charge of
something incredibly dangerous doing
what he thinks is the right thing to do
but then you have on the other side this
other character named L which is sort of
a contrast of his character very quirky
very funny and light but also extremely
intelligent who is on the side of the
law with things no what you're doing is
wrong I'm gonna stop you so you get this
sort of cat-and-mouse chase between the
whole series which is probably one of
the best Catamounts chases I've ever
seen it has some of my favorite moments
in any anime ever and it's just such an
interesting concept of what is right and
what is wrong with the film with this
live movie adaptation they basically
said okay well let's take everything
that is good out of this anime and
remove it just get rid of it I don't
want to see anything good in this film
except for you it was cool but whatever
apparently the director of this film
received death threats because fans were
just so upset about some of the choices
in this film first of all it's
completely Americanized so there's no
Japanese cast so people already start
cultural appropriation
apparently at a mine Winegard had to
delete his twitter because people were
just too mean to mean about the choices
in this family some at least one person
sat down and wrote Adam Wingard
in their notebook some [ __ ] someone
tried someone must have tried and I just
want to criticize his film I like some
of Adams previous work
I thought your next was really good so I
try to go into this with an open mind
thinking okay while I you know what I
want to enjoyed this I want I want to
like this what's so great about the
anime is the two main characters and how
they interact with each other as I
explained Yagami lied who is genius
you couldn't have a more perfect
character to find this Death Note
he is extremely calculated nothing gets
past this guy and oh I bet he has a huge
dick as well when he first discovers the
Death Note
he's extremely cautious with it and he
wants to make sure that no one else no
one else can find out that he has this
because obviously that would mean huge
consequences so he built this
contraction that holds it in you see
once the ink reservoir is inserted it
acts as an insulator preventing the flow
of electricity around the circuit when
light finds the Death Note in the live
adapt ation you know you think he's
being smart with it as well but now he
just [ __ ] goes to gym class and rates
it in public and then he shows this to
this girl to get laid no I say no too
far he went too far
he was a sociopath just because he's
dead does not
I just wish I'd seen it
well actually said I'm guessing this
girl is supposed to be me sat on this
[ __ ] girl which is probably one of
the most annoying characters ever in the
anime Misa gets thrown into the mix of
the story and it's she sort of just
messes everything up because she's so
goddamn annoying but in the anime he
uses her to further himself he uses her
to get his goal to get to his goal of
becoming this gone that he wants to be
here in the movie he uses it to get laid
he want he does it to get laid
god [ __ ] how you have probably one of
the most interesting characters of all
time and you just reduce him to this
[ __ ] pathetic little [ __ ] hmm now
let me just be clear and and spoiler
alert here okay Yagami like is game okay
Yagami backwards is I'm gay if you if
you want more proof than that I don't
know what to tell you but I do have it
so shut up this is one part in the anime
that no a lot of people don't seem to
understand they're like that was weird
why what just happened it's because
they're you think okay what are you
doing here
it's this part where L massages his feet
I thought I might help you out you were
busy wiping yourself off anyway
how does Hollywood make a gay character
straight I thought they were supposed to
be progressive I always read it as you
have the character Yagami line who he's
he's a sociopath he only loves himself
but he has at least the character l that
he sees as his equal someone on his
level and that's the only person that he
could at least other than himself care
about that's why that's how I saw it at
least and that's how I saw the
relationship later on they introduced L
in the movie and it's
it's probably the character that is the
closest to the actual anime he's this
quirky character he eats the sweets all
the time he sits in a real weird way
he's just a weird character and he is
that way because he's supposed to be the
contrast of of Yagami who is this really
calculated composed always keep it cool
character but I guess that doesn't
matter I don't know why they just
[ __ ] whatever when Ellie's
introducing the anime very early he does
something so smart and so clever that
you're like whoa this guy is actually
for real you know this is actually a
true rival to two Yagami lying here in
the movie you really just get all he did
something really smart
here he is it's the epitome of show
don't tell they just went with the
easier option so Yagami and his gay
little girlfriend are they just start
killing people together she's the one
really pushing for it it's really lame I
don't understand it
but yeah they keep killing all the
criminals yadda yadda yadda super lame
ruin my life and ya know they have
computer science class and they're like
hey let's go to 4chan and look up people
people to kill and then they introduce
the only sort of interesting concept of
the film which is can we really kill
people just based on rumors which is of
course never explored again so it
doesn't really matter but in the anime
you have this amazing concept of is it
two to two people wanting justice l and
Kira they both want justice but they
have different ideas of how that looks
like so they go against each other I
mean that's brilliant there's also the
concept of Yagami light he thinks he's
doing good but it's actually evil it's
actually pretty messed up and by the end
of it you think okay well he see a bad
character is he a bad person or did the
deaf node turn into a put him into a bad
person or bad people inherently bad
people or do they become bad people when
things affect them is that explored in
the film no it isn't it's basically
reduced to
oh let's go to 4-channel look at bad
people let's kill them no we can't do
that you crazy [ __ ]
whatever you're not getting my [ __ ] but
you know at least in the movie you get
to see the head explodes really sploosh
a heads everyone's head is just made of
gelatin apparently I don't even know if
I can show it get it but everyone who
dies basically is just made of rubber
they're made of gelatin that's pretty
cool we also get the funny face
reactions I mean look at this fine piece
of acting right here in the actors
defense I sort of understand what he's
going for
Yagami light always has these strange
looking faces there's some there's some
stills from the anime that I just like
but what happened here but that that's
the thing cuz Yagami is his character
and he's always composed no matter what
you know even if he's discovered even if
it's at the brink of you know losing
everything he's always composed so when
he breaks character it's a big deal and
you're like whoa and he makes these
crazy looking faces so I understand that
he's trying to make funny faces based on
like the anime but it just like dude
it's not that's not how that's not why
Hillar keep still
but people are just hating on him so
much for making this faces I I get it I
don't think it was that bad to be on it
I don't know out of all all the bad
things out of the movie I don't think
it's the worst there's even a chase
scene in the film
I'm not kidding there's a chase scene
why is there a chase scene Hollywood you
have this two smartest people in it and
they have a conflict what did they do
they chase each other
[Music]
my camera stopped working Here I am a
day later and I'm gonna try and finish
this video the point I was making with
the chase Ella and lime are two
intellectuals in the anime they know who
each other are and it's all about out
weighting each other it's all about who
can be the first one to outwit the other
and expose him
they are both perfectly aware of each
other and what they are not but
seemingly everyone else doesn't really
understand what's going on but these
guys are just on another level but then
you have them on a goddamn chazy
it's so stupid that's the only way I can
express it to scream why did you have to
murder these characters I don't
understand make a remake fine but make
it of something else god damn it you
ruin blam for me
you ruined one of my favorite mangas
Netflix I can barely look at it now
everyone's like oh I watched that
favorite manga that you have fun it was
[ __ ] yeah of course it was chicken extra
credit shake this is on my phone watch
def note it's an amazing anime you'll
love it I think it's a no matter what
age you are or who you are it's like
it's a classic and if you need any more
ending my recommendation
I got you fam don't worry about it just
write a comment also leave a like if you
enjoyed this video it's very different
but I like to do different things or
liba know if it works out and Squad fair
map